what i do is more than a manicure it's
micro activism you can be cute and
multifaceted and vocal about your
message
my name is amy vega and i'm a nail
artist out of new york city
i became a nail artist by chance it was
always something i did for myself since
i was maybe 13 years old and i thought
about it and i wanted to pursue it more
seriously so i went to nail school and
got my license so i work on fashion
shoots but nar is mostly what i do
i think socially conscious nail art is
important now more than ever because of
the things going on not just in our
country but all around the world
everything under black lives matter
women's rights lgbt rights women's
health domestic violence against women
is also another one
no matter what you have on your nails
they bring attention
it brings your eyes to their nails
it kind of brings the conversation into
real life nowadays we depend so much on
social media and it kind of just brings
that interaction of person to person
somebody will see your nail art and want
to inquire and then you have a moment an
opportunity to talk about that topic
it's more than just being cute and
having cute nails it's having a message
and feeling strong about it and be vocal
about it as a woman sometimes we're made
to be a bit more submissive and this is
a way of kind of getting strength in our
own messages and saying hey i am going
to be cute but i also have a message to
say and
i'm going to wear it on my fingers you
know to be an activist means to feel
strongly about something whatever it may
be
more than anything staying true to
yourself and your message
you